someone was screaming inside the
incinerator
the year was 1975. the location was a
top secret refinery and waste disposal
plant
one of the many front organizations
owned and operated by the scp
foundation this sprawling facility
separated into three different
huge units each with a specialized task
was located around 75 kilometers outside
of
summer springs colorado it had operated
for several decades without incident
but today all hell was about to break
loose
alarms were blaring in unit c the area
of the facility that dealt with
destroying non-anomalous waste via
incineration
a traumatized worker had pulled the
emergency lever near one of the
incinerators
in a panic when he'd first heard the
loud banging against the interior walls
and then those horrific pained whales
that's when workers of unit c came to a
horrifying realization
the screams weren't just coming from one
of the incinerators in unit c
they were coming from all six a chorus
of absolute agony echoing up out of the
ash pits
this was impossible as far as the unit c
staff were concerned
these incinerators were only to be used
for confirmed non-anomalous material
could some animals or even some poor
workers somehow fallen into the
incinerators
but even if they had what were the odds
that someone had fallen in
all six of them at once it was
impossible
the site director was immediately
brought in to authorize an investigation
at which point he determined that at
least one of the furnaces
in this case furnace number four be shut
off so researchers and guards could
investigate what was going on
inside it seemed like the obvious course
of action
but for some of the people on site that
day this would prove to be a fatal
mistake
when the fires were put out something
started rattling in the disposal shoot
there was a scratching and squealing
noise
like something scraping up against the
metal a maintenance worker was ordered
to go check inside and when he opened
the hatch
he let out a bone chilling shriek there
was something
or was it someone climbing back up the
disposal chute
it emerged from the darkness backlit by
the still-burning embers of the
incinerator
letting out an awful screeching noise
that could make even a hardened mobile
task force operative
shake with fear the creature was
humanoid
a charred mutilated skeleton reaching
out towards the maintenance worker with
a bony claw
before the worker had a chance to
stumble back in horror
the beast had clasped him by the throat
and started to squeeze
it didn't even need to strangle him the
heat of its skeletal hand
burned away the worker's throat in
seconds leaving his limp wheezing body
to drop to the metal grade of the
platform below him
several armed guards and maintenance
workers move forward to fend off the
monster
but just then a volley of more violent
shrieks echoed out of the chute behind
it
it only took seconds for over a dozen
more creatures to crawl out of the
disposal chute
they were all like the first people at
various stages of incineration
some were glowing charred skeletons with
barely any flesh
others looking more like severe burn
victims
their faces contoured into scales of
hate and rage
the assembled guards opened fire on the
sudden influx of anomalies
emptying the magazines of their
submachine guns into their burning
bodies
but their weapons didn't seem to cause
any lasting damage
the bullets would tear through the flesh
of the creatures causing some of them to
stumble and fall
but the wounds would close and the
creatures would rise again
it seemed they possessed a deadly combo
of extremely high aggression
and incredible regenerative abilities
none of the staff present in unit c were
safe as the burning corpses attacked
anyone they could find with their bare
hands
beating and biting and clawing many of
them would grapple with foundation
personnel
latching on to them and trying to pull
them back down into the incinerator with
them
these creatures that would later be
known as scp-2419-a
caused several fatalities with their
surprise attack that day
and the situation was only brought back
under control when a mobile task force
that possessed more advanced training
and weaponry was dispatched to the
location
despite orders from the site director
the mtf found it impossible to actually
terminate any of the entities due to
their regenerative
abilities instead the mtf agents focused
on forcing the anomalies back into the
chute
of incinerator number four using a
powerful industrial steam lance
once they were back inside the
incinerator's burners were started up
once again
the mtfs were also able to capture five
of the entities
and detain them for questioning and
experimentation
finally bringing this unexpected
containment breach
to an end the foundation is an
organization that prides itself on
possessing forbidden and
secret knowledge but even they had no
idea what had just happened
there seemed to be no earthly
explanation why these creatures would
suddenly manifest inside the
incinerators
but as the detained anomalies continued
regenerating
a slightly clearer picture of what
exactly the foundation was dealing with
began to emerge every single one of the
captured anomalies kept regenerating
and upon getting to the point that they
were no longer burned scarred
the researchers studying the anomalous
creatures discovered that each one was
identical to a deceased d-class from the
foundation's records
they were physically and genetically
identical to the dead class-d
personnel perfect copies saved for the
fact that their sole mission and life
seemed to now be pure
and unmitigated aggression and violence
researchers wanted to gain greater
insight into the minds of these strange
creatures through the use of extensive
psychological evaluations
and interviews it would turn out to be a
very
dangerous investigation a psychological
researcher by the name of dr warren
conducted an
interview with one of the scp-2419a
instances in hopes of better
understanding their mindset
this creature had been heard laughing
not long before the interview began
so it wasn't an unreasonable assumption
to believe that i could be
capable of speech the interviewee was
separated from dr warren by a thick pane
of glass to prevent it from indulging in
any of its more violent
urges the problem was that dr warren and
his assistant researchers had severely
underestimated what these creatures were
capable of doing
to get what they wanted dr warren tried
to begin the interview in good
faith he spoke calmly and politely to
the creature through the glass
attempting to remind it of the person it
once was
the anomaly didn't appear to be paying
attention to the doctor though
instead focusing on pulling its own arm
apart
and breaking the bones within dr warren
began to think that the creatures
weren't even
sentient if the only activity they
seemed to engage in was the wonton
destruction of themselves and others
but underestimating them like this
proved to be a big
mistake by removing the skin off of its
arm and whittling its bone down to sharp
edges the anomaly had transformed its
arm into a makeshift knife
before anyone realized this it had
already used its own jagged bones to
break the glass divider and attack dr
warren he perished not long after after
being stabbed multiple times in his face
and
eyes and the anomaly was forcefully
taken back to its holding cell
dr daniel jennings a senior researcher
was then put on the case
he released a chilling memo of the
creatures after his observation period
ended it read before i came here i
worked as a prison shrink
every person you met had a story
bursting with pain and sorrow
sometimes these stories were about the
pain they suffered
sometimes it was about the pain they
inflicted
some days you felt like everyone there
was a beautiful soul
torn down by their circumstances other
days you'd find out what some of them
did and a part of you was glad that they
were there to suffer for it
but at the end of every day i always
told myself
they're all humans they're all people
they all deserve the same dignity
respect and love as everyone else
no exceptions dr jennings goes on
i opened up with that anecdote only so
that you could understand that what i'm
about to say
is not said lightly these things
are not people they are people shaped
monsters they are well beyond any
definition of psychopathy
everything they do they do to hurt
maim and kill i would pity them
but that would imply that they're worth
pitying put them
in a hole then fill that hole with
concrete
better still throw them back into the
incinerator where you found them
i doubt they'll even care following this
string of unfortunate incidents
containment procedures were put into
place to hopefully prevent anything that
had happened to the unlucky foundation
staff from happening again
the entire facility was fenced off and
was constantly patrolled by mtf beta 7
also known as the maz hatters a group
specializing in containing anomalies
which present
powerful biological chemical or
radiological dangers
the furnaces that the anomalous
creatures emerge from remain
lit at all times with workers checking
and carrying out maintenance on every
single one
each day of the week outside of this the
facility is essentially a no-go zone
reinforced steel hatches cover the
shoots and they are to forever remain
bolted shut all because of that one
terrifying day
in 1975. that was the day that the
summer springs waste disposal facility
which had been a valuable asset to the
foundation for decades
instead became classified as the
euclid-class anomaly
scp-2419 it is not uncommon for a
foundation
asset to one day become a dangerous
anomaly requiring containment
but the same question always pops up
after why
what had a place that had been so
valuable to the foundation
suddenly become such an active danger
the answer as is
often the case is contained within the
question
why would a waste disposal plant be so
important to the foundation
in the first place and more importantly
what else was going on at the plant to
make it such an area of active
importance for one of the most powerful
organizations in the entire world to put
it simply
the plant allowed the foundation to
dispose of something far
more important than mere waste material
it gave them what they needed to better
erase memories as you probably already
know
the foundation makes liberal use of
amnesics on those
exposed to anomalous material to make
them forget
what they had seen and experienced but
these elusive chemicals
many of which are sourced from scp-3000
are an inexact science
however at the summer springs waste
disposal plant researchers discovered an
immensely valuable
alternative much of what was disposed of
in the incinerators of unit c
were the bodies of dead d-class
personnel before being burned
autopsies were performed on the bodies
to make sure they were non-anomalous
including the brain back in the 1960s
while performing research on the brains
of dead d-classes
they found a method of extracting and
distilling the positive memories of the
dead
creating a kind of happy soup when
administered into someone who has
undergone amnesic treatment
this happy soup creates positive false
memories in their mind that fills in
those pesky blank spaces that are often
behind this was so useful that happy
memories were extracted from the minds
of every single d-class corpse that
passed through unit c
totaling well into the thousands by the
time that the first
scp-2419-a instances began
to rise but as all happiness joy and
love were removed from the minds of the
d-classes
it seemed that all that was left was
pure hate
pain violence and fury feelings too
intense
and evil to destroy these were bodies
imbued with a malice so powerful that no
fire could ever burn them away they
exist now with single-minded
determination to get out and destroy
everything around them everything
including the ones that made them
the scp foundation itself and
in the end it's only a matter of time
until they get out
there are thousands of them in there
unable to die
unable to stop the only thing keeping
them in there is the constant burning of
the furnaces around them
and those furnaces can't burn forever
the monsters lurking in scp-2419 will
outlive the fire that surrounds them
because while the furnaces they are
contained in are hot
the fires of hate that burn within
scp-2419
entities are even more powerful and they
know this
they know they can't be contained
forever and that someday soon
they'll be able to emerge and exact
their terrible
revenge those who must walk past the
incinerators may think they hear
their screams echoing out from within
but it's not screaming at
all it's laughter now check out scp-1861
the crew of the hms wintershire
and scp-3999 i am at the center of
everything that happens to me
for more tales of terror from the scp
foundation